des jeux qui n'attendent qu'à retrouver
leur passionnés au manga bas les équipes
patiente mais avec leur terrasse et une
extension proposé par la mairie
l'humeur est plutôt au beau fixe on
n'est pas dépité
maintenant c'est vrai que on croit en
nos deux bars dans notre clientèle on
élit ce temps là ils sont présents on
les voit quand on vend des pizzas on
sait qu'ils vont être la large ouverture
maintenant c'est vrai que pour nous au
niveau de la gestion on a un petit peu
pas dépité mais disons qu'on a perdu un
an au niveau de la gestion a pris du
retard voire même deux ans puisqu'il va
falloir un an pour pouvoir rattraper le
retard de cette année les propriétaires
ont mis les différents confinement à
profit pour améliorer leurs cartes avant
mars 2020 le manga bas réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires mensuel de 50000
euros
allez voir s'activer en cuisine on
pourrait croire que tout a déjà repris
mais damien bouteloup et son équipe sont
aux fourneaux pour les plats à emporter
300 couverts sur quatre jours le ch a
fini mon teint prend son mal en patience
je pense que nous on a assez subi voilà
maintenant on continue notre job
satisfaire comme les clients qui
continuent à venir chez nous et puis
vacances à rouvrir à je pense que je
serai le premier de 100% donc voilà on
attend on est dans la tente
on a essayé de rénover un peu les
cuisines qu'on en a profité aussi pour
faire 2 3 2 3 travaux maintenant on
attend de voir ce qu'ils vont nous dire
lasser rapidement pour le tablier aussi
la terrasse sera la première bouffée
d'air frais le président de la
république a fixé à mi mai la date de
réouverture